>From this point onward, we will consider
linear programs in their standard form,
where the constraints
are expressed as e qualities.
We will have an underdetermined
system of equations, that has lots of
solutions, and we'll try to find the one
that maximizes the objective function.
Now, if you've ever had to come up with
solution to an underdetermined system on
your own, you'll have noticed that it's
easiest to find one by simply setting
some of the coefficients to 0,
so as to create a square system,
and then solving for
the rest of the coefficients.
In effect, this is what solvers
like MATLAB do, as well.
These solutions are called
basic solutions.
And it turns out that to
solve linear programs,
basic solutions are the only ones
that we will need to consider.
The trick however, is figuring out
which coefficients need to be set to 0.
With that intuition in mind,
let's dive into the details.
Switching over now entirely to
considering linear programs in
standard form.
I want to define some vocabulary
that will be useful going forward.
First, we say that a vector x is
a solution if and only if Ax = b.
A basic solution is one
generated as follows.
We'll pick an increasing
sequence of m column numbers so
that the corresponding columns
are linearly independent.
And we'll call the resulting matrix B.
This is easiest to see when
the chosen columns are the first m.
And we'll use this convention for
most of our treatment.
We define XB to be B
inverse times this B here,
and then embed this
in a longer vector x.
Putting the value from XB for
columns in the sequence and 0 otherwise.
This x is a basic solution.
Really, all that we're trying to
accomplish here is to let XB get
multiplied with the columns of B and 0
to get multiplied with the columns of D.
Remember that post multiplication
corresponds to column operations.
So that then is a basic solution and
we call it basic because it came
from our choice of this linearly
independent set of columns which
forms a basis for the column space.
>From this basis we get a basic solution.
It is possible for more than one basis
to yield the same basic solution
if some of the entries of this XB are 0.
Such a solution is called degenerate.
This corresponds to the case where
our vertex is at the intersection
of more than n hyperplanes
in the symmetric form.
So far this vocabulary only
addresses the equality constraints.
Adding in the non-negativity
constraints in the variables,
we use the word feasible,
thus a feasibly solution is a solution
that has all nonnegative entries.
And a basic feasible solution
is one that comes from a basis
as described above and
has all nonnegative entries.